all right what's going on I got a couple
of reads here before we start the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast where I just
check in on you and then I do an
interview so I don't interrupt the
interview all right I'm basically
becoming Charlie Rose all right quip
everybody the truth is most of it most
of us are brushing our teeth wrong
not for long enough and forget to change
our brush on time that's because most
brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks
rather than better brushing but not quip
so well for starters quip is an electric
toothbrush that's a fraction of the cost
of bulky of brushes while still packing
just the right amount of vibrations to
help clean your teeth ladies keep it
clean quit builts quips built-in at G's
if the text message is hear quip built
quips built-in timer [ __ ] helps you
clean for the dentist's recommended two
minutes with guided pulses that remind
you when to switch sides
next I gotta get one of these how does
it remind you all right party next quip
subscription plans are for your health
not just convenience they deliver new
brush heads on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five dollars including free shipping
worldwide quip also comes with a mount
that suctions right to your mirror and
unstick to use as a cover for hygienic
travel wherever you take your teeth oh
yeah you got to cover your brush Jesus
and finally everyone loves quip they
were named on Oprah's Oh named one of
Times best inventions and is the first
subscription electric toothbrush
accepted by the American Dental
Association not the United Kingdom
Dental Association that's huge anybody
can get their recommendation because
evidently they're asleep at the wheel
but the America
in Dental Association plus their date
back there they're backed by a network
of over 20,000 dentists and hygienists
and hundreds of thousands of happy
brushers used quip everyday quips starts
at just 25 bucks and if you go to get
quip comm GE t q u IP comm slash Burpee
u RR right now righ t [ __ ] with you
you'll get your first refill pack for
free with equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack yeah yeah
at get quip comm slash bars spelled GE t
qu IP calm / burr and lastly but
certainly not least ly Go Daddy Go Daddy
is the world's largest technological
technology platform got him stupid for
small business so if she for small
businesses what's the plural business
businesses I started a couple of
businesses you'd never get a second date
you guys say I'm an entrepreneur you can
sit across there was spaghetti hanging
on your mouth go nice well what am i
doing since high school while I started
a couple of small businesses they helped
regular people get their businesses
running and thriving with just about
everything you need to make an ideal
real these days
that means do-it-yourself websites I
can't believe it figured out DIY email
social tools and even a business phone
app for your Apple or Android may just
for small businesses check them out
they'll do right by you
well there's no links or anything now
she said I emailed you too this is a
two-parter everybody all right here we
go
where's the rest of this oh that's it
they'll do right by you oh yeah Go Daddy
go daddy.com
Go Daddy you can do it buddy all right
that's it now why don't we listen to the
interview here with the one and only
Patrick
[Music]
all right you ready all right hey what's
going on it's bill burn it's time for
the Thursday Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
then I'm just checking in on you whose
phone is that is that my phone I believe
it or not I am at the Indianapolis Motor
Speedway here in what is it Bloomington
no Indianapolis Indiana
Speedway Indiana and I have a very
special guest a lovely lady coming to
the podcast the one and only Danica
Patrick thanks what's going on you know
just taking in the sights and sounds hey
I used to work in a dental office with
my dad by the way
lovely dentition oh right out of the
gate I've been doing the Invisalign by
the way which i think is a it's a great
thing kind of straightened out my teeth
down on the bottom but they make it seem
like they're like you're just gonna wear
it for like three months and then you
have like this night guard thing and I'm
finding that it isn't you kind of have
to wear these things for the rest of
time or else you go right back to having
like snaggle teeth so it's kind of
annoying so they basically get you
they're like you get so happy with your
new smile and then they lock you in
because they're like you're on the hor
well it must be your fault that your
teeth don't stay like this guess you're
gonna have to wear them forever yeah and
they're gonna and I'm gonna owe this guy
money money money money the whole time I
should have known I screwed up so
anyways I don't think you have probably
some what straight teeth Oh money yeah I
got a little bit of money I go out there
I tell my [ __ ] jokes or whatever we just
went around the track in a I was saying
this this this Camaro the color of my
pubes there was a little wimpy that it
was a convertible you know do you feel
like that was slow in your dash you
rather put the top down should be great
we could put on some jewel you know you
know forty miles an hour yeah I've done
that one other time and I was really
nervous with the other person but you
have like this steely calm where you
were cruising around you just sort of
like you know I'm trying to make my
stupid you know you know I'm a dancing
monkey impress my clown jokes and you're
just looking over like distracting was
like riding distress
in you were sort of finding yourself
like feeling and seeing and anticipating
and getting nervous at any point or were
you just like rolling like it was a
couple of times you came close to the
wall and I was feeling my face getting
pulled towards the wall that I was kind
of like all right I just kept thinking
you know she's done this a zillion times
and she has to work on Sunday so she
doesn't want to wreck this thing and
then I was of course also thinking
there's really no roll bar this is just
sort of a very moment yeah very fancy
very high-quality seat belts hey how
come an IndyCar like I noticed this year
in Formula One they have that ridiculous
thing that's now it looks like it's in
there in their line of sight that little
halo thing that they have going just you
know being exposed as dangerous right so
they're you know there have been drivers
killed through things hitting them
crashing parts of the car actually the
cars have a little wicker on the front
of the cockpit where it opens up right
in front of the steering wheel obviously
if you be able to get in so it's clear
it's like a plexiglass piece hmm and
that's what I'm looking through
basically when I'm looking down the
front straightaway
looking at cars just before I get into
the corner I'd say I maybe look a little
past it to the to the left when I'm when
I'm getting into the corner but for the
most part I'm looking through it and
that that thing gets so many like chips
and bugs and all kinds of stuff like I
feel like I'm you know drunk by the end
I'm like I can't see what's going on
what's the scariest thing like accent
you've been in like that you must die at
this point as long as you've been doing
it had like a wheel or I would just
think of a lug nut going you know 2,200
miles an hour coming at you I mean
that's got to be terrifying let's see my
first accident an Indy car was really
big I ended up going in an ambulance to
the hospital like you know full speed
and I kept asking the nurses how if it
looked bad apparently I was obsessed
with the idea of like I'm oh I'm alive
but it looked really gruesome cool yeah
and there reminded me that I had asked
them three times now and so I didn't
realize that because I was
forgetful so what though I said that it
look bad you saying like did you look
bad like you you all know the accident
look bad like what's happened to the car
did it look like
catastrophic was it exciting was it you
know did it look good are you shocked
I'm here you know what I realized when I
came here I went to this race in 95 and
96 I was telling you and you know I'm
not gonna lie you want to see an
accident you want to see it you probably
it's probably really annoying that's
like somebody going to a comedy club and
wanting to see somebody bomb but what
you don't realize is you think you want
it to be right in front of you because
you're not thinking of the physics that
like I saw a guy hit the wall right in
front of me just like no with this tires
but it's just like he hit it there and
all the all the action was like
immediately a quarter mile down the
track so you want it to happen like a
half mile up the track or however far if
you're really gonna see all the all of
the action I feel bad saying that to you
but I did I mean you want to see an
amazing race you want to see something
you know it's that's why I used to watch
chips back in the day wasn't for the
banter between ponch and Jon it was for
like the that giant pileup
I'm probably dating myself you probably
don't even remember that show I think
that show came out probably before you
buy it is the little tool but I have
heard of it you know what's great about
that is they always have like these
freeway pileups and that would go on for
like a minute and then in the end there
was always the guy that somehow got air
and went over the top of it and if you
listen to the sound effects he was still
on the gas pedal which was the funniest
you think he'd hit the brakes at that
point in the air he was in the earth you
know what I had to end up learning with
um
stock car racing because I did that for
seven years was that the best thing to
do if you were about to if you were
spinning out or anything was happening
was just Matt it keep the wheels
straight and keep it floored is that
Matt it means oh man it put us down to
the foot it down pedal to the metal
yeah what is that like when you're
driving that fast everybody's spinning
out all you see is smoke and you just
hope you hit in the hole yeah I mean
it's like poke and hope you know you're
just hoping that they clear they clear
away and the right there like you know
when they when cars crash especially
stock cars and when there's
lots of them because the pileups and
stock-car racing tend to be a little bit
bigger than an IndyCar racing but he but
either way generally the cars you don't
know where they're gonna go they're like
footballs bouncing you throw it and it
hits the ground you're like God which
way is he gonna go that's how it feels
when you're like trying to decide where
to go
based on the car like there was a car
that crashed in front of me in practice
and it hit the right outside wall on the
right and then I wasn't sure if it was
like gonna cut across the track somehow
right in front of me so I just kind of
waited waited waited waited and then as
soon as you think you're clear you just
gunned it and you just get by it was now
if they had you miked up if I heard you
on TV just going [ __ ] actually exactly
what I'm thinking before anything
happens
[Music]
hey so what's the most I'm just jump
around here as far as like I know you've
probably got a lot of [ __ ] for being a
woman you know in this you know this is
a guys was stock car was they I'm just
picturing them being more sexist because
I'm a northerner probably like when you
showed up with air like what are you
gonna do here darlin you gonna ride
around in the pace car did you get a lot
of that did get people that said to me
like how are you gonna handle these big
cars you know and I'm like a lot easier
because they have power steering yeah
well sure they're hot but they're not
harder to drive physically they're much
less physical to drive was it like one
of those Hollywood movies did some guy
likes a bunch of sexist stuff to you and
then you beat him and then the end he
had to walk up be like if someone said a
bunch of all right I would beat them you
would in some way maybe verbally but
probably start verbally and then I don't
think it would escalate to anything
physical but I would verbally abuse them
now did that ever happen maybe I don't
want you to name names yeah I'm not
gonna talk about do you remember a quote
game do you remember a quote what's it
what's what did you well I do remember
there was quote a long time back from
you've got an f1 hat on Bernie
Ecclestone said that women should be
wearing like white like appliances and
be in the kitchen or something like that
oh he said that
[Music]
it's always I think all that stuff's
funny but it does then you go out and
you beat the person and you prove them
wrong
right I don't really take it that
personally I just don't it's interesting
it creates some drama and some something
to talk about but I don't take it
personally
so now you're gonna uh and I'm really
jealous about this is you're gonna
retire I think that's awesome I think
it's awesome - I'm super excited I'm
like you know I I don't know how it
feels for you and you walk out on stage
or before you do this with me or I don't
know how you feel when you interview
somebody but like I'm just excited to be
gone from that stress like I'm excited
to have I'm excited for less polarizing
sort of emotions of you know so so happy
and so so scared or so mad or so sad but
you can die doing what you do like my
job is the most fun job ever it's just
getting there because all I think is if
I retired I would be like I would never
go to LAX ever again and that's amazing
right I would never have to connect
through Heathrow which is one of the
worst experiences I ever had I had to
get off go get my bag that I checked and
then like get on a bus there was like
three forms of transportation to get to
a whole whole other side of the airport
now just ever since that I was just like
I'm never why did they kiss what do they
kiss we're standing right we're right on
the finish line is these tourists
they're kissing that's the thing you do
after you win the races kiss the bricks
oh you do yeah I don't you know
everybody's look at it and then what
she's gonna walk across it you know he
went to the men's room
oh you can sign it I guess you guys just
wear it off after like three laps yeah
really and they leave with the dream
that it's still there someday if you
ever go to that race you're gonna see my
name right down there so yeah she ran
over my name how often do you like beat
yourself up after races or would you I
should say man every one of them for the
most part yeah I mean you're always
thinking about what you could have done
better I feel like that's the nature of
a competitive mind
of someone very driven like I'm not just
what's what's the worst as far as like
as far as racing goes I would think
you're leading with like two laps to go
and that somebody gets around you you
run out of gas running out of gas is not
your fault really so I would say that's
the lesser of them unless they told you
where this guy go when you run out of
gas does he just leave the hole this
this he immediately get fired I mean I
feel like I use fueled and you know
pulled the pulled the fuel fuelling hose
out too soon and didn't get it full
something like that it would be him now
if it was your engineers not putting
enough in or not taking to account what
was going on and not telling you to save
more then it was them if they told you
to save fuel and you didn't then it was
you so it could be a series of I don't
understand what after the race is like
it's like alright there's a giant finger
where we going to point it a little bit
yeah a little bit I think there's always
you know given the fact that the driver
has the most amount of decisions to make
come race time with passing and restarts
and nailing pit stops getting into your
pit box well getting out of it you know
all pit out just you name it like
there's so many different things the
driver has the most amount of things
that could be their fault I would say
that generally before the race it's
probably a little bit more on the team
you know preparing the car and then of
course working on it engineering it and
making sure the changes are good and
getting the balance right for race day
and anticipating the the weather
conditions and you know how that'll
affect the car aerodynamically so those
those decisions become theirs but then
in the race you know the driver has a
little bit more weight on the shoulders
what would you have to do in the pit
crew to get fired like how many times
can you screw up so that guy short feels
you're right well you're probably not
gonna get fired till after the race but
actually that's not true there there are
times where pit crews let's say somebody
falls out of the race or sometimes it'll
be the middle of the race I think I've
seen this before with like Jimmie
Johnson or something you know they'll
swap pit crews in the middle of the race
and just feel like you know what we need
your picture of you can take ours really
wait
they switch with different drivers
different different guys changing the
tires for the four different driver
doesn't matter tires or tires so anytime
I watch the race if I see somebody run
out of gas to fuel guys fired if it's
his fault probably not but you know it's
probably a little like baseball yeah you
can only you know you can give up so
many home runs before you're gonna go
back down to the minors yeah there's
only so many strikes you get against
yourself alright so you're you're gonna
retire after this race and then you
mentioned you have you have your own
line of wine is that how you say it I
have my own have my own label I make my
own wine I make jungle juice no you're
big drinker I'm a big drinker that's why
I'm a couple of bottles down before you
get out there on the track just take the
edge off loosen up I can't imagine I
don't even want to take like a Tylenol
before I go out let alone
it seems II just going around in that
rental car who's kidding who glorified
rental car we just went around like that
that would be you know you said you were
going twice as fast as this you know
we're going half the speed of what I'm
doing in it yeah and there's some right
oh yes it seems like it's a pretty
terrifying sport yeah probably don't
want to be drunk yeah but yeah I make
wine so I bought of I bought a property
in Napa Valley in 2009 smart and just
dirt and then planted a vineyard oh it
wasn't a vineyard usually started from
scratch from scratch how do you figure
out how to do that I had a lot of help
from who was my friend at that point in
time a winemaker
he is my winemaker now so you know I met
him at it really goes back to why I
started falling out of something on the
grapes enough I met him back in 2006 on
a vacation there and he worked at
Quintessa at that point only and he was
you know he he was just happy to be
there that day it was during sort of the
end of crush period so it's November
time and it was a cool nice beautiful
morning and you know the valleys got a
little bit of fog in it and you know
it's kind of you know pulling back down
into towards San Francisco into the bay
you know I'm sitting there on this
beautiful grassy knoll overlooking the
vineyard rose petals leading out to this
place romantic comedy oh yeah it's it's
not gonna get real funny though
unfortunately it's gonna get more
expensive
high-pressure system moving yeah so um I
just stood there and I thought man this
is just so cool like how amazing would
it be to have something like this
someday and that I in my mind thought
this would most 50 million dollars I
don't know what do I need to do this and
I thought I don't have that kind of
money yet and and they're like you said
yet I really believe that I was like
look I'm I'm might have 50 million
dollars someday to be able to do this
but but I I started slow so went back a
couple years later and looked at some
properties and errand pot is my
winemakers name Aaron kind of helped
pick Aaron pot is you wine maker yep so
I grow something else too okay and if
too many people grow it in your state
then you have too much product and then
you can't ship it out because then it
becomes a federal offense once you go
across state lines why do you know so
much about this I don't know I'm not
really a pot smoker I'll do it
occasionally like when I'm not drinking
I just I just get bored being me you
know so I just don't I I what I like
about drinking is I feel like I earn
getting buzzed we're you know drinking
whiskey it's like you got to get it down
you know what I mean give me another one
we're just like a man at the end you're
like I drank all that whiskey not even
that it's just like I feel like like
we'd smoke and it's just like getting
[ __ ] up with like training wheels on
it's like you don't have to work you
just a couple of puffs especially now
that stuff there I mean I don't know
what the old stuff was like as I never
tried it to like my late 30s and all
that does it just puts me they take two
puffs and then you just kind of like for
two seconds my god kind of cool and then
I just fall asleep where booze a little
bit of a slower process you can kind of
enjoy the growing the the escalation of
the buzz you know I also know where it's
going I know okay if I control it if I
have three of these I know kind
where I'm gonna be at how fast I drink
them and it's not like you take one sip
and that's one it's the whole drink you
have many many sips of your ointment you
can have a whole conversation instead of
a shame pager a little bass and then all
of a sudden you're like wait yeah you
see and stuff now they it's it's - you
just sit there cool I remember from high
school basing outright as though I don't
know what it's called I thought base it
was smoking like coke all I know is that
gonna butter mine you can tell you can
tell you still got the glow look at me I
look like a curmudgeon I got a buddy of
mine he's like he's a year older than me
and he actually kind of stopped smoking
weed
because he's just like dude I miss the
old stuff you know what I mean you just
sort of smoked it you felt alright he
goes now it's just like you take two
hits you like tripping and I think
that's just because there's so many
people growing it now and they gotta
have theirs be like more intense and
stronger than the next yeah I all I know
is this is a big thing with somebody
somebody needs to make the Pinot Noir of
weed then a little lighter something you
can sort of smoke all evening maybe or
sporadically through the evening it's
more it's a lighter red wine you just
sold the hell out of that to me you know
what my wife wants to go up there so
like what's the difference between it's
a Cabernet Cabernet Cabernet and alo
Merlot well you know ruined Merlot it
was that guy who played Pig vomit and uh
in the Howard Stern where I can never
remember people's names then the same
name is a guy who ran a league can't
remember his name remember he said he
was in that movie he's like I am not
tricking Merlot Oh sideways
yeah I don't remember their names I
there's Paul Giovanni Giovanni yeah so
everybody who did know [ __ ] about wine
like me I was thinking like Oh Merlot's
like this that's like drinking Eddie
yeah yeah so it literally affected sales
of Merlot and Pinot Noir went up what is
your fav you like it I make a cab I make
a cab and then we decided last year to
use the cab to make arroz a which turned
out amazing we sold out of that really
fast so luckily we're gonna be able to
make more next year than we did this
year
and then I have a 71 blanc coming out as
well that we purchased grapes for that
one in from Knights Valley so and what
is uh what's the name of your wine it's
a Latin word so every time I say for the
first time people are like what but it's
not that hard it's the name of the wine
is called somnium which means dream in
Latin because I told you about my little
dream about like having a owning of
owning something like Quintessa someday
right something like I'd love to have a
winery and I'd love to be able to do
this whole experience and own it and
make it and yeah it was my dream and so
it's a Latin word for dream so like
insomnia or yeah dream
you're making me one on by a winery you
can just pop by mine and you know to you
whenever you like
maybe I'll just do it in my backyard
I'll have a couple of bushes of grapes
and I'll just make my own wine I'll just
podcast I gotta figure out her I gotta
figure out a way where I don't have to
go to the [ __ ] Airport every six days
there's got to be some kind of
technology where you can see someone
somewhere else I know I know that Motor
Speedway at half race pace if you
weren't here so yeah if you want the
experiences and you want the connection
I appreciate you going the extra weight
mile the extra twelve hundred miles
there you go Oh from LA yeah I took the
red-eye I took the little counts those
miles still count
what are these are punishing what other
sports sleep on a red-eye can you sleep
on airplanes yeah yeah I can't I do but
usually you want to get the window seat
so you don't get that tap you know and
you like someone's got to go up and go
to the bathroom but I had the I'll see
me by the way
the Perot you you got a weak bladder I
like I just drink a lot of water
speaking of it's a great idea you drink
a lot of water why because it's really
good for you okay that wasn't
challenging you know just askin yeah
this way I wasn't trying to pass you I
work out a lot so I do a lot and then
you work out a lot what else do you do
um I sweat in race cars
and you know just generally a sweaty
person you know one of those people that
you don't do that uh what is that stupid
thing week from yoga know the people
where they got a run down the street so
you know that they're working out that's
it
what do you call it [ __ ] it's it's a new
kind of working out where you run down
there's usually like a garage door they
have it open and they're making all
kinds of noise and their mouths across
fit I do that run down the street well
because you needed to accomplish your
400 meter run that's part of your
workout don't you don't you just trying
to run by people sitting down eating
brunch to make them feel guilty because
every time I sit down I get a little
Florentine huh if you had gotten done
with your workout already and we're at
breakfast you'd be thinking to yourself
I've already done that but instead
you're feeling guilty yeah but I would
want the person to know that if they ran
by me it's a little self reflection
moment you see somebody working out and
it reflects back to you that you're not
I think you blaming a victim one of us
is blaming the victim
one of us is being a jerk here right now
and I have the only thing that makes me
it's me I feel guilty when I see
somebody working out thinking to myself
I could do a two a day right and I do
two a days as often as I can but I'm
like man I wish I had more time to work
out what do you uh what is it what is
your workout crossfit mostly I do
[Music]
jumping jacks you know the the way that
the classes are usually structure
they're an hour and the beginning is
some kind of a warm-up some kind of just
shake it out some kind of maybe a
gymnastics move there's a tight position
I already can't do this workout then
there's usually an Olympic lifts that
you work on so deadlift weight scenes
that were you gotta like squat all the
way down to press back squat yeah yeah
yeah just there's the actual workout
part and the workout is between geez
anywhere from like five or seven minutes
to 25 minutes that's pretty much what
the workouts are in CrossFit they
usually range around the 12 to 15 why
would a regular person like me ever want
to put that kind of weight up over my
head squatting down blowing
my knees and then trying to blast up
like what-what is that gonna do for me
as don't you want to kind of like take
it easy on your body well I mean laughs
lead I guess you know weights and impact
on some level does actually strengthen
your bones who said that the people who
make the weights because you gotta look
to see where it comes from cuz I get my
lifetime eggs have been good for you bad
for you and then great bad for you yes
so like cigarettes I did you watch what
the health no but I watched that I'm
like I'm just gonna die tomorrow oh yeah
as far as everything that's in our food
right and they told you sugar wasn't bad
in that one they're like now eggs are
like smoking and you know it's just fine
I'm like I'm so confused who is putting
this [ __ ] out there that's confusing me
no way sugars good for you bad for you I
would have died ten years ago are you
two eggs every morning I love eggs yeah
they taste too good to be bad what's
Cinnabon and I feel too good when I have
animal meat so I can't imagine how
that's but it's a byproduct of the Sun
if it's not made by the Sun you
shouldn't eat it I do stand by that it
sounds good to me
I'd have to sit down and work that out
like I mean an animal's a byproduct of
the Sun they eat the grass that's grown
by the Sun vegetables made by the Sun
right fruits now is your is your uh you
know but for the most part is your are
your Cheerios made by the Sun I love
Cheerios but daddy refined but I put I
put bananas on top of it made by the Sun
that's better
yes maybe go for the whole banana and
maybe some almond butter with it I got
it was so like yesterday seeking what I
was oh it's that I would not you are
pasty but you're not you're not the
other because I'm turning 50 next month
so I said at least I got I got a I got
to get myself in good shape here you
look I do it you look like you're in
shape so don't know you know what you
you said you look good and then you
looked away you and you look good you
just sort of look down you don't
down and I was like you look good so I
get on the airplane tomorrow with a
bunch of people headed to New York to do
media day for the Indy 500 you have to
leave here and then come back yeah yeah
when well actually that was Monday night
gosh sorry that was Monday night after
practice we went and so there's food on
the airplane and so we're kind of like
handing it out you know here those lazy
bastards come out here
I mean Franco they don't have to leave
where the Superbowl is right actually
every driver went there there were like
one or two drivers in each location but
there was like 30 for drivers out in
America doing media promos and spread it
out cause if you saw it on TV you know
it's not gonna leave the state here
right well yeah there was a lot of local
TV done I'm sure so anyway I get on that
we get on the plane we're Dan in the
food out and then they're handing out
like the dressings and the bread rolls
now like anyone want bread and I'm like
I look back and I'm like you know
there's absolutely nothing in that the
the nothing in that food that's gonna
help you there's zero it's like no
nutritionists know all the other drivers
are know I told that well there was they
weren't there weren't any other drivers
they were just it was a few guys few
girls on the plane they're just people
from NASCAR or people from IndyCar my
people whatever so anyway yeah so anyway
I told the girls that their bread rolls
I was like there's nothing in that
that's gonna help you nothing is gonna
so you were talking about coming in your
kitchen and critiquing your food this is
this is what I would do so anyway I told
them I went on a long diatribe of all
the things that I all my opinions and
thoughts and feelings and well you know
what they didn't eat it they didn't need
it there you go
yeah but I bet when we started talking
about chia pudding and somebody had it
for breakfast the next day and they were
very excited and I was like I'm so proud
of you what is she a pudding
well it's Hsieh seeds mixed with some
kind of a milk what a cheese so cheese
these are the little tiny little balls
and when they when they come in contact
with the liquid the outs they puff up
almost like a chia pet
like chia pet but like like a tapioca
kind of thing where they they get like a
little gel membrane around the outside
of the seed and so it becomes more like
pudding I just felt like it was on the
$10,000 pyramid you
these clues and I wasn't gonna guess
okay this thing it kind of makes itself
bigger you just add is it a grain liquid
and it's not a grain that sounds
absolutely disgusting is gross
I hate pudding it's just like it's like
it was gonna be something and it quit
halfway before it got there it just
feels like it is kind of boring until
you put stuff with it like fruits and
you know granola and crunchy things I'm
a whole I'm a big fan of the obviously
my life is filled with just dualities of
you know super stressful super relaxed
like there's me meditating and then
there's me going 235 miles an hour
and then like food wise I like sweet and
salty combined crunchy creamy combined
well drives me nuts you know the I
wasn't I was telling my story Oh Dale
you wouldn't want like a salted caramel
ice cream what's wrong with you no and I
don't want like a kid says who would
want to salted ice creams yeah it's just
because they like you know you know it's
because I'm gonna give him salted ice
cream salted caramel it's part of its
that's like a generation gap thing like
I went in to get a an ice cream the
other day I was in San Francisco and
it's one of these artisan places sure
like pistachio goat cheese whatever yeah
they had they had chocolate rose petal
or something I said what happens just
chocolate what what is that there's no
way they put rose petals in there that's
good yeah they do they have rosewater
mists and all kinds of things you can
extract the oil from rose petals it's
very expensive so I bet it was the most
expensive ones why did you pick it I
know I ordered mint chocolate chip I
could just have mint chocolate chip and
they go no it's not in season it's like
yeah you're making ice cream here you're
killing anybody that's ever grown mint
knows that that never dies so it's
always sweet greens I'm pretty sure
chocolate chips don't ever go I don't
even have a season then all the time see
I needed you then and for the or your
knowledge I mean a little earpiece to
say that to him so I just went to
Walgreens and I walked in and they had a
pint of the mint stuff and I I just
bought that and I didn't think what kill
me was I didn't want to eat the whole
pint but now I had to because I bought
it you know
and I was a waste bomb a mama I'm with
you I don't like to waste food either it
was really killing me to leave food on
the airplane last night and I was like
maybe you just give it to the drug dogs
as you walk out of the airport that's
what I do I pet them that's what I do
they still scare the [ __ ] I don't have
any drugs on me so I'm confident that I
can go put I don't either but what if
the dogs having a bad day what if it was
just a it just you know it messed up
then all of a sudden it starts staring
at you whatever the hell it does well
when it's really mad it won't stare at
you have you ever raced in Singapore no
all right I did a gig in Singapore and
that's where like they you know they put
people to death all the time I've never
been so terrified walking through
customs like I made sure I look through
my bag like a thousand I don't even do
drugs but like you get like the death
penalty over there is something abroad
like where you get locked locked up
abroad yeah that made me not want to
travel seriously yeah but people kept
going should scare you I'm out you get
the motion really sharing my feelings
know the ocean um I would say you had
the ocean the ocean is my number one
fear falling overboard and just sitting
there without a sharp object where I
could just stabbed myself in the neck
before the Sharks get there and then
kind of go under and bleed out real fast
well yeah because I was sitting there
looking at like at Hawaii well I mean I
don't think this thing as much as a
tiger shark cuz they come up they take a
bite out of you see if you're edible cuz
they're like what the [ __ ] kind of fish
is that then they take a bite all right
I think I'll go back in for the second
and you're just sitting there and your
heads above the water
you take three bites you know if you
don't want to eat something so it does
it I can see what you're saying here
yeah no it's just it's absolutely so
you're scared of sharks I'm scared of
sharks I'm scared of that Alumnus of
just being out there so when you try so
do you not like being alone period like
are you one of those people who's gotta
have a buddy around I'm a total loner I
love being alone I like drinking alone
that's cool yeah cool I guess no I
actually drink alone you know what I
drank alone by myself
after qualifying I had a good qualifying
weekend you know come back spend seven
years I qualified seventh my guys is
pretty good so I great home and
everybody wanted to go out doing stuff
and I'm like I just you know like no and
I try to see if somebody wanted to go
and then they didn't text me back so I
was like you know it so I sat by myself
and drank a glass of my own somnium wine
yeah because and then I said to my
parents afterwards because I'm I'm
staying at my parents house so which is
just funny I said hey I took some of
your wine but I did one that I took one
at least that I could replace for you so
I drank alone I know I know the feeling
sometimes just relaxing it's nice it
gets a little weird when you go to the
second glass I'm not gonna lie to you
yeah you're kind of like wait what am I
doing this for
stop feeling like you're in barf like my
buddy DeRosa was telling me that he goes
I love drinking a lot he made Joe DeRosa
made it okay so if he's listen and I
want to thank him but uh Oh getting back
to my diet I didn't I didn't get to tell
you this guy Dean Delray he's just seen
him like like maybe three years ago he
looked like he had been like the
stereotypical like a cop that's what he
looked like like he'd been you know just
sitting in a cruiser eating bad food
tacos and doughnuts and all of that and
he got diagnosed as having like the
diabetes that you can get rid of
whatever type that is and he just said
one yeah he went on like this he
actually listened to the doctor he read
up on nutrition and he lost all of this
weight he doesn't even look like the
same person he went from like almost 200
pounds and he's a little shorter than I
I am I'm almost 510 sometimes I lie I
lie on my driver's license because I'm 5
9 and 3/4 I got a bump it up right
that's okay I'm 5-1 and a half and I'd
write that if I could yeah what do you
what do you say any drivers like I'd
rather be if I'm gonna be short my
little real short go ahead all right
I'll say four so he looks better he lost
a bunch of weight he looks amazing and
then now he's done a bunch of us comics
on the diets what every morning I
basically I'll have like steel-cut oats
and then a couple eggs over-easy which
evidently are gonna kill me
then in between I'll have like Ezekiel
toast which is the devil is the way it
tastes but you just put almond butter
that's all right and then the quinoa
kena was the [ __ ] quinoa I say quinoa
quinoa I also say nuclear
I say all other grains it has a lot of
protein and fiber in it
sexy you see it's not a grain you wanted
five bucks because I bred it
let's look it up look it up tell me I
want to know cuz I think it's a seat I'm
in my diet I am everything lutein free
bean bean free and so if this turns out
to be a seed and not a grain I don't
know even though it's called the mother
of grains oh it is yeah listen once a
podcast I make a complete ass of myself
and I think that this is gonna be it
okay well we've got like six people in
here they can probably look up whether
or not quinoa is a grain or a seed
what's the verdict it's a seed crisp
singles I swear to god somebody give me
some milk here that I can drink for that
victory look at that no way I just blew
your mind I wish you guys could see the
look on her face right now I love it I
need to see I love it what the hell hey
the proofs in the pudding
that's a call back sweetheart quinoa
cedar grain quinoa is a seed that
harvested from the species of a plant
called goosefoot part of a group of
pseudo cereals making it neither a grain
neither a cereal nor grain and could be
related to spinach and beets then to
cereals or grains holy [ __ ] there you go
I'm going I'm gonna have a mind blown
I'm back on the train I mean look I
think you need a glass of wine right now
oh my god I do
um you know the pinot noir of marijuana
apparently i got to be honest with you I
think this I've been doing this podcast
for coming up on 11 years I think this
is the first time anybody's ever learned
anything this is like a legendary moment
I know you have before this airs can you
like lay in some triumphant music
background and there's no production
quality this is all this is well listen
I know you have to get back to racing I
cannot even begin to tell you what a UH
as far as I can of racing like what a
thrill that was every time we went down
the straightaway and I saw whatever you
call that thing when they show that the
leaders and all at the tree there I mean
this is uh it's incredible thank you so
much for doing that I'm definitely going
to get some of you why can people you
got a website where they can order it
yeah somnium wine calm you got to spell
it for my listeners som and I um
it's phonetic it's just a weird words he
really didn't spell it for them in fact
on the front of the bottle on the front
of the bottle there is the breakdown
like syllable by syllable is is
underneath the word so that people can
definitely get some of that and what
should I go with what do you think get
the penis cab I know I don't make it
point out I don't really like fino
actually okay I'll get the rosette cuz I
love a rosy yeah and don't in this
Avenue a bunk you know round it all off
you've got you know summer spring and
fall and winter covered I'll drink them
all by myself in my hotel room tonight
alright Danica Patrick everybody about
to retire driving her last race I'm so
happy for you you know that you you're
doing what you want to do yeah it's
awesome
I got relaxed listening hosting the
ESPYs and I'm still hosting the SBU told
me all the keys to the kingdom for that
one yeah having never host an award show
you said make sure you drink before you
go out there it's not for camera for
yourself yeah take a shot of Jameson I
all or if I just completely lose my
train of thought basically if I end up
saying boom goes the dynamite it's
because I'm drunk there you go just
relax
smile have a good time make fun of
yourself if a joke bombs make fun of the
fact that it bombed just be be in them
up you're gonna be great you're gonna be
great and at some point I hope my wife
can get up what is it what is the name
of the one I'm a booze guy that's the
one place somnium my oh no no no
Napa Valley Napa Valley that's where the
wine is everybody alright thank you
listen to podcast hang in there we got a
little little music here and then we'll
have a half hour greatest hits from a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast
[Music]
so anyways I go I go to the airport and
I'm taking the red-eye taking this 1055
flight now [ __ ] stop cuz that's how I
do it
alright I'm on a good plane why would I
want to get off it and switch and roll
the dice and get on another one you know
let's just [ __ ] get there when it
when I Drive up to San Francisco I don't
pull over and [ __ ] Burbank and then
getting hit no another cut we get it
built alright so I get on the [ __ ]
plane right I use my miles bump myself
up like a fancy person you know maybe
maybe I invented the Cheesecake Factory
people are thinking and then they see
how I'm dressed and they go oh no he did
invent the Cheesecake Factory
um and I go to go to sit down on my seat
and I go to set my bag down I was gonna
set it down right in front of me and the
nice fella sitting next to me goes once
you stick it in the middle of his room
and he moved his bag out of the way I'm
like alright this guy's a solid dude or
whatever and then all of a sudden the
waitress comes by my stewardess whatever
she comes by flight attendant whatever
the [ __ ] he's supposed to call him she
comes up and she could I get you jelly
to drink and I was like yeah can I get
out I'm gonna get a water please ice or
no ice
what however you make it stop acting
like it's a [ __ ] martini it's warrick
just give me a water with ice thank you
and the guy next to me he orders a
Dewar's neat no ice no nothing just put
it in there so they bring our drinks
alright and I'm really thirsty so I
start sucking mine down and he just
throws his back like it's nothing like
[ __ ] John Wayne right before he's
gonna turn around and beat up three guys
three mustachioed guys in the 1930s
right so I'm just sitting there and
everybody's getting on the flight you
know and I'm looking around at the
passengers you know I'm [ __ ] doing
whatever I'm doing and all of a sudden
the guy next to me mr. doers goes to me
he goes excuse me he goes are you afraid
to fly and I looked down as I want
he goes are you afraid to fly and I go
no no I'm not and he goes because all
right but you know it's because it's
okay you know it it's okay to tell me if
you're afraid to fly and it's
immediately getting weird and I'm like
no I'm not afraid to fly and then I'm
thinking in my head wait is he afraid to
fly and that's why he's drinking the way
he just drank and now he's hoping that
I'm gonna be afraid to fly so he you
know he just wants to open up that's
what I'm thinking and I'm like yeah no
I'm not afraid to fly and he won't leave
it alone he goes alright because you
know your your your fidgeting your
looking around at other passengers and
I'm looking at this guy [ __ ] serious
and I go no I go I'm not afraid to fly
so now I'm like [ __ ] this guy I'm not
talking this guy for less to the flight
this guy's weird man it's like 30 just
get paint the pictures like 32 year old
wiry in shape but like wiry white dude
he's got a skully cap on with [ __ ]
glasses you know and he goes uh like
there's like a minute of silence and
people still getting on the plane and
then he goes hey sorry about that sorry
we just we just got off on the wrong
foot he's like my name is so-and-so he
goes what's your name and then I'm
thinking in my head like what's my name
my name's Frank I wanted to give him
like a flyby just some buddies I just
wanted it's Bill and he goes oh hey Bill
and he goes nice to meet you so we shake
hands and I'm just looking at I don't
have any poker face I'm looking at the
guy like what the [ __ ] is your problem
I'm not even trying to not I'm not
trying to be pleasant I'm already done
with this guy so then the guy goes oh
hey Bill he goes why you going in
Annapolis bill right like he's [ __ ]
interrogating me and I I'm like is this
guy [ __ ] serious and I start doing
the math in my head go in is this guy
like an air marshal or something and I'm
like no he's not he's [ __ ] slamming
booze over here [ __ ] this guy so I just
go
I go look I don't have to answer your
questions that's it and I just looked
straight forward
he goes okay now I'm concerned okay I am
concerned and I'm looking at him like
concerned about what because you're
fidgeting you're you you have issues
with other passengers and bla bla bla
bla he sucks Paton I clicked it's like
he's been I don't know what the [ __ ]
like psychologically breaking me down
all right so now just by this point
they've closed the [ __ ] the door to
the fuselage and we're starting to taxi
and I just finally look at the guy and I
and I go I go you know I came out with
the flight one point I literally stick
my hand out because he kept saying I was
nervous and I stick my hand right in
front of his face and I hold it level oh
that's what I did the first time yeah I
hold it level I go I'm not nervous and
he goes well anybody can do that
and that's when I was like [ __ ] this guy
I'm not talking to the guy sorry [ __ ]
this story up then Denny Denny came back
got my name now he's going why are you
going to Indianapolis and I finally look
at him I say listen pal I'm drinking
waters you're drinking doers okay
there's no issue over here and then he
goes it wasn't doers what she gave me
wasn't doers really what was it some
sort of spy juice you [ __ ] jerk-off
this point I want to punch him right
through his [ __ ] stupid wiry glasses
right so he's going like you looking
around hostels and I said something that
just ticked him off that was a sad dude
I go I don't have to answer your
questions all right leave me alone and
then he goes he goes - he goes he starts
going like okay I am really concerned
right now he was why you going to
Indianapolis and I just look at him you
know when I start doing I start doing
like this Ryan Gosling you know that
little smirk that [ __ ] mono Lisa's
smile he has is he smirks his way
through all this [ __ ] movies I do but
I go full on Ryan Gosling now I'm not
talking to this guy and I just keep
looking at him and I gave him that
little half a smirk and I just shake my
head that's my game now that's this is
Mike it's like if you're gonna be a dick
right now with your [ __ ] delusional
authority right that you're going to
like we're in [ __ ] Guantanamo and
you're gonna waterboard me huh
there's no water there's no board don't
[ __ ] yourself here's my smirk and I'm
just gonna shake my head at you like
you're a [ __ ] pathetic human being
this is what I'm doing right and this is
the funny thing I'm such a dick all I
have to say to the guys I'm a comedian
I'm gonna do a sold-out show there and
that would make him back off but I'm a
dick I'm like [ __ ] this guy I want to
see where this is going so now he's all
[ __ ] amped up and he starts dropping
f you know you see saying the F word he
sitting there going phew he goes you
don't [ __ ] answer my question right
[ __ ] now I am gonna hit that call
button we're sitting there taxi and down
and [ __ ] getting in line I'm gonna
[ __ ] hit this [ __ ] button if you
blah blah blah and I'm just [ __ ] mono
Lisa's smile smirking just shaking my
head like you were a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right so now he's he's saying the F word
so much the lady who's sitting in front
of me diagonally in front right in front
of him turns around and looks at us and
now my heart's racing I'm like where's
this going this is gonna be great I am a
hundred percent [ __ ] innocent this
guy's drunk and I think he's going to
hit that button what's gonna happen
right I want to see what the pilot looks
like
let's see where the [ __ ] this is going
right so he goes you [ __ ] you he start
such bring his hand up to the button
going I'm gonna hit that button you
don't think I'll [ __ ] do it I'll hit
that button and I'm sitting there
smirking and I'm thinking in my head go
ahead hit the [ __ ] button let's see
what happens let's see what happens
right so finally now he wants to hit the
button and he can't [ __ ] find it and
it's in in defense of him I couldn't
find it either I was looking up that I
half wanted to hit it myself then he
finally finally finds it and he hits it
right and now I'm just like holy [ __ ]
what's gonna happen and he's sitting
there going yeah huh you want to [ __ ]
play this game you want to [ __ ] play
this game and I'm surprised I mean it
took like [ __ ] like 30 seconds before
a flight attendant the one who gave him
the booze which evidently wasn't booze
comes over and at this point we're like
doing that [ __ ] where we're behind a
plane we're almost ready to take off
like we're pulling up and then stop and
pull it up then stop and as planes had
taken off so she goes yeah what's the
problem over here and he goes I'm not
comfortable to fly with this guy this
guy he's fidgeting he's looking around
[ __ ] people blah blah blah Blee is
doing all this thing right and then the
stewardess looks at me and I'm just
sitting there [ __ ] my little smart
just shaking my head and I just looking
at just shaking my head like this guy's
out of his [ __ ] mind I don't say a
word and this guy goes on and on and on
about his [ __ ] psycho babble about
how I'm the security risk so she goes -
so she goes okay any other passengers
have you noticed anything she's talking
everybody first class this has anybody
noticed anything odd about this guy and
the lady who was sitting right in front
of the dude diagonally from me turns
around she goes yeah I've been listening
to this guy bright berating this other
passenger she's on my side and I haven't
said a [ __ ] word this is great and
I'm just sitting there smirking then
they lit stewardess looks at me and I
shrugged my shoulders like I don't know
what to tell you so finally she said sir
dude do you have anything to add to this
and I just said look I'm just a guy
trying to go to Indianapolis this guy
over here he starts slamming his doors I
kind of felt like a rat when I said that
I go slamming his doors next thing you
know he's dropping the f-bomb to me then
I'm thinking ah [ __ ] I just said bomb
right fortunately nothing happens so now
another [ __ ] the male stewardess
comes over right now he's going like
what's going on and the captain of the
[ __ ] now at this point we pulled over
in the plane has stopped 250 people
trying to get to Indianapolis and jerk
off over here can't hold this [ __ ]
alcohol who just watched Person of
Interest
every every August evidently I have no
[ __ ] idea now the plane is stopped
this [ __ ] jerk-off has stopped the
plane interrogating a goddamn comedian
like I'm in the [ __ ] Taliban and like
he works for the CIA right so now we're
just sitting and the captain is up front
in the plane like saying to the
stewardesses going basically relaying do
I really have to [ __ ] come back there
this is the last flight of the night is
that really a goddamn problem and that
divide and they finally said to the
douche sitting next to me are you gonna
be okay to fly with him and at that
point it appeased his [ __ ] ego that
he was somehow in control and he goes
like you know what okay it's fine it's
fine it'll be fine it'll be fine
so they go okay so now the planes going
again and now what now we [ __ ] come
around and he's sitting they have
[ __ ] he's in my ear and at this point
I am lat like the [ __ ] laugh you hear
me doing the podcast that's what I'm
doing and he's sitting there going ah he
goes you know what I'm glad I'm glad you
say I hope you [ __ ] do I hope you
[ __ ] try something I hope you [ __ ]
try something when we're up there I
really hope you [ __ ] try something
and I'm just [ __ ] like gut-busting
laughing shake him out like what are you
gonna [ __ ] do to me what are you
gonna do to me
I'm you're gonna punch me in the face
you [ __ ] wiry jackass if you have
[ __ ] glasses on you know that's a
federal offense you're gonna go to jail
if you do that or something I don't know
what right so I'm just saying it [ __ ]
laughing the guy going I actually at one
point I put my [ __ ] little eye pillow
thing on do you know like I'm going to
sleep oh I had that out to when the
stewardess was talking to me I was like
putting it on is this total mind [ __ ]
like I I don't know what this guy is I'm
just trying to go to Indianapolis I'm
going to sleep and so I got I got my
[ __ ] eye thing on right as he's
sitting there threatening me just I was
going with total passive-aggressive it's
like dude I'm so not concerned with you
I'm literally putting a blindfold on all
right so this [ __ ] guy he starts
going he goes he goes you think you
[ __ ] won this you did you [ __ ] won
this he goes might you know my dad is my
daddy's sorry saying his dad's some
major CEO in Indianapolis doesn't sound
like a [ __ ] made-up story I swear to
god this is all true he goes Mike my dad
is some a major CEO in Indianapolis and
I'll have you [ __ ] arrested and the
lady turns around again I would have you
[ __ ] arrested the second we get on
the ground I'm thinking like for what
for what sitting here you [ __ ] loser
learn how to hold your alcohol right and
he starts describing the view that I'm
gonna have when I go to jail like some
[ __ ] Law & Order episode
oh you're gonna love it you'd be able to
see Lucas Oil Field and buy the bat the
bat and I'm just sitting there cracking
up laughing and then there's this pause
right
and I'm thinking finally he finally shut
the [ __ ] up it's like a three four
minute pause he finally just gave up cuz
I wasn't giving him anything I was just
laughing and shaking my head I was being
a dick to him I was because I was
enjoying it and then there was like a
three-minute pause then all of a sudden
he just goes why you going to
Indianapolis bill so we're like 20
minutes into the flight and I got my
honesty's my adrenaline was so going
during all of that cuz I knew I didn't
do anything wrong but I thought we were
literally gonna go back and there was
gonna be [ __ ] cops there and have
like if if the [ __ ] stewardess or the
pilot asked me who I am and where I'm
going I'm gonna tell him I respect your
authority
you're just some general you don't have
any [ __ ] authority I don't have to
answer your questions it was prot was
one of the most fun experiences I've
ever had with another human being like
when somebody thinks that they have
power and you know they don't and all
they can do is try to just keep bluffing
and raising their voice and start
cursing at you and if you just start
laughing at them the look on their face
is [ __ ] priceless
so Blasi he said he said why are you
going indianapolis bill right and i
[ __ ] started howling just [ __ ]
hold in my stomach shake in my head and
with my [ __ ] eye pillow thing on
right and I know I'm gonna get a ton of
[ __ ] that I wear one of those I they're
[ __ ] underrated get the one at
Brookstone where it's literally a pillow
I'm telling you you could fall asleep 12
noon facing the Sun it's awesome
so anyways like after he asked me what
what you no way you're going bill you're
like there was like a 10 minute like
probably ten minutes had gone by and I
can't [ __ ] sleep because it's so fun
to me I can't wait to tell the story to
every comic I know
I can't wait to try it on stage to see
if it's funny or whatever so finally I
just like that [ __ ] it maybe I'll just
get on my computer and I bring up my eye
pillow and I like I got a look at the
guy cuz I know he's [ __ ] staring at
me waiting for me to do something right
so I lift it up I get my [ __ ] mono
Lisa's smile going and I look over at
the guy and dude he is [ __ ] passed
out he looked like he got shot he was
sitting there like his head was just
hanging straight down and any time the
plane moved like his head was I mean he
look like you got knocked out and for
the rest of the [ __ ] flight oh
[ __ ] uh what's Matt Damon's character
isn't Jack Ryan
old [ __ ] Jack Ryan over here is just
you know the sky marshal the [ __ ]
booze bag and God knows what else he was
on he was just completely out passed out
for the rest of the [ __ ] flight and
this is what I went to dick I am I was
having so much fun with this guy I start
I can't sleep so I start slamming waters
because I want to have to get up and
take a piss just to see if this guy's
gonna freak out because this security
risk is getting up and this the joke was
on me he never regained consciousness
and then I really had to take a piss but
I'm such a stubborn [ __ ] I was holding
it cuz I wanted to make sure he was
awake when I got up because I was gonna
give him a little smirk and then I was
gonna get up see he hit the call button
again but he didn't he didn't wake up
till we hit the ground and and then it's
funny then he woke up it was like four
hours later so now he had kind of slept
off whatever the [ __ ] this guy was on
and I'm sitting there smirking waiting
for the guy to start talking I mean he
won't look at me and I and I think at
that point he kind of [ __ ] realized
that maybe he got a little uh a little
extra little too patriotic so we stopped
we stopped at the gate and everything
and we're going to get up so I grabbed
my [ __ ] I get up and I'm just kind of
looking at him and he won't look at me
and then the lady who was sitting in
front of me
I had this big smile on her face she
goes how you she goes how you doing I
don't want good I go that I go that was
an interesting one and I said it really
loud so the guy heard and he didn't say
anything and this is what he did to try
to save face his pillow was kind of
stuck behind was kind of stuck behind
his shoulder in like a weird place so he
was frustrated with it so he ripped it
out from behind him and kind of threw it
down on the floor when yeah like try to
do some caveman grunt to try to still
have some sort of I don't know what so
so that was my flight to Indianapolis
people you know what how far we did a
[ __ ] podcast are we that was a long
that was a long [ __ ] story
[Music]
you